rain that's wonderful and we need more
of it don't we we got already we've got
those clouds uh some alto cumulus clouds
they're starting to build over the
mountains and let's let's hope that they
open up with some nice water by the
afternoon i had to laugh yesterday
evening because the murphy family
had dueling rainbow photos going and
sending them to me cindy murphy had this
gorgeous shot of a rainbow over the palm
trees right looking out of their front
street and her husband wayne was also
sending me his rainbow photos at the
same time i'm like wait a minute
murphy's it was a full-on rainbow shots
they were loving it it was beautiful in
the sky thank you for all the good
rainbow shots that we've been receiving
trying to share all those with our
viewers it was really lovely in the
evening last night all right so we did
get a little bit of rain again in the
evening and it was nice other spots got
more rain than the valley we've got 70s
60s out on the west side lots of good
humidity out there in the air 74 in
mesquite 82 in laughlin 64 in front
sandy valley and prep both got some nice
rain yesterday
over a tenth of an inch in both spots
almost a tenth up in the mountains mount
charleston a quarter of an inch around
good springs and a third of an inch just
about at mountains mountain pass
just a trace officially in las vegas
that's all we got that a couple of times
really with some passing showers but we
sure hope that we could get some more
now today they may come in the form of
thunderstorms with dangerous lightning
as well as strong gusty winds so we
still have moisture in place this was a
pretty good little cluster of
thunderstorms last night before midnight
through the pahrump valley things are
quiet this morning but we've got daytime
heating we've got this low pressure
system opening up into california and
spreading inland and so between the two
we might wind up with some thunderstorms
today please get out of the swimming
pool off the golf course wide open
spaces not safe to be if you're ever
caught in a wide open space during a
lightning storm you need to crouch down
cover your head and be the lowest spot
you can be in an open area strikes can
actually reach out 10 miles from the
parent storm cells so dangerous to be
outdoors you need to get inside in a
covered enclosed area 101 today we'll
start seeing clouds building up and that
chance of thunderstorms in the afternoon
and evening hours and then some breezy
westerly winds tonight into tomorrow and
then we dry out and warm up into the
weekend 105 and even a little hotter
early next week